From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Lilly Sullivan, sitting in for Ira Glass. A while back, we got an email from a listener in a small town in Utah. He wrote, "It seems like half the town has a huge elementary-school-style crush on a local veterinarian." And I wanted to know, could this be real? So I flew to Utah. And I went to the place people would a local vet, the dog park.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是莉莉·沙利文，代班艾拉·格拉斯。前段时间，我们收到了一位犹他州小镇听众的邮件。他写道：“镇上一半的人似乎都像小学生一样，对当地的一位兽医着迷。”我想知道，这可能是真的吗？于是我飞往犹他州。我去了人们会见到当地兽医的地方——狗狗公园。
[DOGS YAPPING]
[狗吠声]
Hey. Can I ask you guys a question? I'm working on a radio story about a vet who works here in town, named Dr. Artz.
嘿。能问你们一个问题吗？我正在做一个关于镇上一位兽医的广播节目，他叫阿茨医生。
Yeah, like Artz, the Heartz Throb?
噢，你是说那个“阿茨——万人迷”吗？
I thought it'd take me a long time to assess this. It didn't.
我本以为要花很长时间才能评估这件事。结果并不需要。
I think different women in town thought he was very attractive. That's what I heard.
我想镇上不同的女性都觉得他很有魅力。我是这么听说的。
He's very attractive, yes.
他非常有魅力，是的。
Everybody talks about the cute vet in town.
每个人都在谈论镇上那个可爱的兽医。
Everybody says that about him.
大家都是这么说他的。
I'm not into Dr Artz. But I'd say he's looking pretty good.
我对阿茨医生没那种想法，但我得说他确实长得很不错。
No, he's-- he's hot. But he's not-- he's totally upstanding. He would never-- but yeah, he's hot, for sure. Sorry.
不，他……他很帅。但他不是那种……他为人非常正派。他绝对不会……但没错，他真的很帅。抱歉。
Did you just say sorry to your husband?
你刚才是在跟你的丈夫道歉吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Ex-husband, he whispers at her.
前夫，她对他耳语道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Most of these people, he wasn't even their vet, though I did talk to someone who knows him as her vet. I'd tell you her name, but she asked that she and her dogs remain anonymous.
这些人大多数甚至不是他的客户，不过我的确跟一位把他当作自家兽医的人聊过。我本可以告诉你她的名字，但她要求她和她的狗保持匿名。
Everybody knows Dr. Artz is a hunk. I refer to him as McDreamy. He's just so cute.
大家都知道阿茨医生是个帅哥。我管他叫“梦中情人”。他实在是太可爱了。
Her husband, Jim, was fine with me using his name because Dr. Artz doesn't know who he is because his wife always volunteers to take their dogs to the vet herself-- alone.
她的丈夫吉姆并不介意我使用他的名字，因为阿茨医生根本不认识他，毕竟他妻子总是主动提出独自带狗狗去看兽医。
So where I really realized-- I think this is the moment I realized that it was a serious crush. I guess we were dating. We had been dating long enough that we were already living in a house together. And she was at this work training. And she called me. And I was at home. And she said, I need you to log in to my computer because I need you to send over a file that I need for this training. And-- are you OK with me telling this story? OK.
所以，我真正意识到……我想这是我意识到那是一种严重迷恋的时刻。我想当时我们正在约会。我们约会的时间已经够长了，已经住在一起了。当时她在参加一个工作培训，她给我打了电话，我还在家里。她说，我需要你登录我的电脑，因为我需要你发一份培训用的文件给我。而且……你介意我讲这个故事吗？好的。
His wife nods and squeezes her eyes shut. She puts her face in her hands.
他的妻子点点头，紧闭双眼，双手捂住了脸。
And it's like, OK, cool. And I ask her, I was like, so-- I got into her computer. And I think I had to log into her email. And I was like, so what's your email password? And she goes, oh, shit. I'm like, what's the deal? And she's just waiting. And she's like-- it goes quiet for a moment. She's like, the password is Dr. Artz for life-- like a teenage girl-- doctor, artz, number 4, L-Y-F-E.
当时我就说，好的，酷。我问她，我就……我进了她的电脑。我想我得登录她的邮箱。我说，那你邮箱密码是什么？她说，噢，该死。我说，怎么了？她就在那等着。她说……沉默了一会儿。她说，密码是“阿茨医生一生推”——就像个少女一样——Doctor，Artz，数字4，L-Y-F-E（一生）。
It was not L-Y-F-E. I spelled that part correctly.
不是L-Y-F-E。那个词我是拼对的。
That's how I remember it. And yeah, I just-- I remember I was like, OK, yeah, wow. This is a real crush. This is a-- he was there before I was.
我是这么记得的。然后是的，我记得当时我就想，好吧，哇。这真是深陷其中了。这是一个……他出现在我之前。
That's so embarrassing.
那太尴尬了。
What's embarrassing about it is the amount of time they spend on this. This woman is on group threads with five other people, men and women, all couples, all straight, in happy relationships. One thread, they told me, is 80% dedicated to either Christmas movies or Dr. Artz. They don't know why they do it. The one sidedness, the degree of it all. It confuses even them.
尴尬的地方在于他们花在这件事上的时间。这位女士和另外五个人在一个群里，有男有女，全是情侣，而且全是异性恋，关系都很幸福。他们告诉我，群里80%的内容要么是圣诞电影，要么是阿茨医生。他们不知道为什么要这么做。这种单方面的迷恋，以及这种程度，连他们自己都感到困惑。
It's not a romantic crush. I don't have a romantic crush on our vet.
这不是浪漫的迷恋。我对我们的兽医没有浪漫幻想。
This is someone else on the thread, Alissa.
这是群里的另一个人，艾丽莎。
But there is something very vulnerable, I think, about admitting that you think about someone more than they would think about you.
但我认为，承认你对某人的关注多过对方对你的关注，是一件非常脆弱的事情。
Nonetheless, at this point, the idea of Dr. Artz has become so omnipresent, they built this whole imagined life for him. Here's Jim again, the guy who found his wife's password, who's never actually met or talked to Dr. Artz.
尽管如此，此时此刻，阿茨医生的形象变得无处不在，他们为他构建了整个虚构的人生。这是吉姆，那个发现妻子密码的人，他实际上从未见过阿茨医生，也没跟他说过话。
I picture that he lives on a ranch somewhere and has a couple of horses. Does he? Didn't you tell me, once, about where he lives? No? No? OK, I guess I made that all up in my head.
我想象他住在某个农场，养了几匹马。他有吗？你曾经跟我说过他住哪儿吗？没有？没有？好吧，我想那都是我脑补出来的。
Say more. What else? Fill it out. Because if you're picturing it, there's probably more there. Right?
多说点。还有什么？补充一下。因为如果你能想象出画面，那可能还有更多细节，对吧？
Yeah, no. He's got a wife and kids. And he lives on a ranch. And he's got horses. He's wearing jeans and a flannel shirt, living on a ranch. Honestly, that's always what I-- did I just put that together in my head, entirely?
是啊，没了。他有妻子和孩子。他住在农场，有马。他穿着牛仔裤和法兰绒衬衫，住在农场。老实说，这一直是我……我是完全自己在脑子里拼凑出来的吗？
Your imagined version of him lives--
你脑海中那个虚构的他住在……
Yes, the wife part-- I'm pretty sure he does have a wife. Right?
对，关于妻子的那部分——我很确定他确实有个妻子，对吧？
He is married. Yes.
他确实结婚了，是的。
How do you know that?
你怎么知道的？
I'm pretty sure he has a ring on his finger.
我很确定他手指上有戒指。
You've looked?
你观察过？
Yes. I always look. You always look.
是的。我总是会看。你也会看。
Max McClorey, the guy who first wrote us about all this, had his own image.
马克斯·麦克洛里，那个最初写信告诉我们这件事的人，也有他自己的想象。
It's this-- him, tending to a stove-top percolator, and--
就是那种……他在用炉灶上的咖啡壶煮咖啡，然后……
This is so specific.
这太具体了。
Yeah, right? My mind just immediately went to this. And then walking out, to watch the sunrise on his porch in like a flannel jacket kind of thing. And that's probably super off base. He probably has a Keurig. I have no idea.
是啊，对吧？我的脑子立刻就浮现出这个画面。然后走出来，穿着法兰绒夹克在门廊看日出。那可能完全离谱。他可能有个胶囊咖啡机。我完全不知道。
But yeah, I've got just this image of him in a cabin, basically. It would be out of character for him to not watch the sunrise with a cup of coffee that probably has some coffee grounds in it. You know?
但没错，我的脑海里基本就是他住在木屋里的样子。如果他不一边喝着可能混着咖啡渣的咖啡一边看日出，那才不像他。你知道吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like, he rides a motorcycle, which again, is he going to like throw his bag on his motorcycle and ride through the countryside with the wind in his hair to go save a horse or something?
就像，他骑着摩托车，而且再一次，他会把包扔在摩托车上，迎着风骑行在乡间小路上，去拯救一匹马什么的吗？
And this is what I'm here to talk about today. I totally understand this thing they're doing, putting so much thought into someone who's basically a stranger, something I do too, that I think lots of us do, but never really name.
而这就是我今天想谈的话题。我完全理解他们的这种行为，把那么多的心思放在一个基本是陌生人的人身上，这事我也做过，我想我们很多人都做过，但从未真正给它命名。
I've never been the most social person on Earth. My natural state seems to be to spend a lot of time alone. But it wasn't until COVID and the prolonged isolation that I started noticing that sometimes random people would walk through my mind, people I had no reason to be thinking about.
我从来不是世界上最擅长社交的人。我的自然状态似乎是花很多时间独处。但直到新冠疫情期间，在长期的隔离下，我才开始注意到，有时随机的人会走进我的脑海里，那些我根本没理由去想的人。
And my mind would just perch there, watching them, for a little while. Nothing loaded, it wasn't a crushy feeling. It's weirdly neutral, actually. I just hover in that scene for a moment. For me, it's usually this person who I really don't know very well.
我的思绪就会停留在那里，注视着他们，过一会儿。没什么沉重的东西，也不是那种迷恋的感觉。其实奇怪地保持中立。我只是在那个场景里徘徊一会儿。对我来说，通常是那个我不太熟悉的人。
I knew her in college. She doesn't live near me. But sometimes, fairly often, I'll picture her just washing dishes in her house, sunlight pouring onto the sink, which I picture is white, even though I can't remember if that's right. There's warm, running water, suds, a few water glasses.
我在大学时认识她。她不住在我附近。但有时，甚至挺频繁地，我会想象她正在自家洗碗，阳光洒在水槽上——虽然我不记得那是不是真的——我想象水槽是白色的。水流温热，泡沫翻涌，放着几个水杯。
The images are like a little coffee break from my own life, where I try on hers for size. It feels nice there, peaceful, and rooted, which aren't feelings I feel a ton of in my own life. She does not know that I do this. And I never want her to find out.
这些画面就像我生活中的一点小小的“咖啡歇息时间”，我试着代入她的生活。那里感觉很美好、平和且扎根，这些都不是我生活中常有的感受。她不知道我这么做。而且我永远不想让她发现。
Today on our show, we lean into this thing that is so awkward that we usually turn away from it. We're calling it the lives of others. I don't know why I do this. But I think it's something so common. So let's talk about it. First stop, Dr. Artz. Does he have any idea how much he's taken over people's brains? Stay with us.
今天的节目，我们来深入探讨这一件非常尴尬、以至于我们通常会避而不谈的事。我们称之为“他人的生活”。我不知道我为什么要这么做。但我认为这太普遍了。所以我们来聊聊吧。第一站，阿茨医生。他知道自己占用了人们多少脑容量吗？请继续收听。
Act One, So, I Hear You're Hot. I drove out to Dr. Artz's house on a sunny winter day, on what I have to say is probably the most cringey assignment I've ever had. And when my GPS told me to turn left off the highway, I got my first unexpected sign, a literal sign, as I entered the driveway. "Lost River Ranch," it read, carved in metal, mounted between two columns of piled boulders. A ranch, just like Jim had imagined.
第一幕，嘿，听说你很火。在一个阳光明媚的冬日，我开车去了阿茨医生的家，我必须得说，这是我做过最让人尴尬的任务。当GPS引导我从高速公路左转时，我进入车道时看到了第一个意想不到的标志，一个真实的标牌。“迷失河牧场”，上面刻着，安装在两根堆砌的巨石柱之间。一个牧场，就像吉姆想象的那样。
I drove down the mountain, past a Jeep Wrangler, an electric blue pickup, past the motorcycles. And then I saw it, cresting atop the hill, a beautiful log cabin. And I met Dr. Artz, or as he calls himself, John.
我沿着山路开车，经过一辆牧马人，一辆电光蓝的皮卡，经过摩托车。然后我看到了它，矗立在山顶，一间美丽的木屋。我见到了阿茨医生，或者像他自称的那样，约翰。
Hi.
嗨。
What's happening? You know, you already got that thing rolling, huh?
在忙什么呢？你知道，你已经让那东西开拍了，是吧？
Yeah, we were just chatting. It's good to see you.
是啊，我们刚才在聊天。很高兴见到你。
You, as well, you as well.
我也很高兴见到你。
Let's just get this out of the way. What does Dr. John Artz look like? There's this Paul Newman thing going on--
我们先把这事儿挑明了吧。约翰·阿茨医生长什么样呢？他身上有一种保罗·纽曼的气质——
I mean, we're done--
我是说，我们要结束了——
--salt-and-pepper hair, hazel eyes that one could accurately characterize as soul piercing. But what you notice most is the way you're hit with a force field of magnetic kindness. And can I just say, there's no normal way to go up to someone and say, professionally, were you aware that everyone has a crush on you?
——椒盐灰色的头发，淡褐色的眼睛，可以准确地形容为直抵灵魂。但你最先注意到的是那种磁性般的亲切感所带来的磁场。我能说句吗？没有正常的方法可以走到某人面前说，从职业角度来看，你知道全镇的人都暗恋你吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
I stumbled through it.
我磕磕绊绊地说了出来。
And-- um-- I'm curious. I guess-- so--
而且……嗯……我很好奇。我猜……所以……
I'm doing my best. OK?
我尽力了，好吧？
The thing that I said in my email is, everyone really likes you, says you're amazing with animals, amazing with people. And the thing that I haven't said yet is that there's a bit of-- there's a town-wide crush--
我在邮件里说的是，大家真的很喜欢你，说你对动物很有一套，对人也很亲切。但我还没说的是，这里有点……镇上的人普遍对你有一种迷恋——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--that people talk about with you.
——人们会谈论这件事。
Right.
好的。
But yeah.
但事实就是这样。
Dr. Artz didn't blink an eye. It wasn't news to him.
阿茨医生眼睛都没眨一下。这对他来说不是新闻。
Well, I think I knew somewhat. And again, it wasn't a constant part of my life. But for instance, where my now-wife used to work, when we started dating, I'd go in to see my wife and have a beer.
嗯，我想我知道一些。再说，这也不是我生活中的常态。但比如，我现在的妻子以前工作的地方，当我们刚开始约会时，我会去见她并喝杯啤酒。
His wife worked at a brew pub in town.
他的妻子在镇上的一家精酿酒馆工作。
And the manager would come up and sit next to me, and put her arm around me, jokingly, like, our book club last night turned into a conversation about you. So I would get that occasionally-- or whatever.
经理会走过来坐在我旁边，开玩笑地搂着我的肩膀说：“昨晚我们的读书会变成了关于你的谈话。”所以我也偶尔会听到这些……或者别的什么的。
Sometimes clients would leave little notes with his receptionist, things like that.
有时客户会给他的接待员留下小纸条之类的。
And most of it's just flattering and harmless and innocent, for sure. But I was appreciative and flattered, yeah, certainly. But that was-- a few people would tell me things like that. And I never extrapolated it to being the whole town was talking about me or anything. I didn't let my imagination run wild by any means.
其中大部分肯定是恭维，无害且天真。我确实很感激并感到受宠若惊，当然了。但这只是……少数几个人告诉过我这些。我从来没有将其推断为全镇都在谈论我什么的。我绝没有让我的想象力肆意妄为。
Oh, no, no. Of course not. Who would ever do something like that? I told him more about how people imagined him.
噢，不，不。当然不会。谁会做那种事呢？我告诉他更多关于人们是如何想象他的。
And the answer I got was-- this is going to sound crazy, but the picture I have is tending to a stove-top coffee percolator, and taking it out to the porch to like watch the sunrise, in a flannel.
得到的回答是——这听起来会很疯狂，但我脑子里的画面是他在炉灶上煮咖啡，然后把它端到门廊上，穿着法兰绒衬衫看日出。
If you look behind me, you just described me, actually. And I love percolators. That's funny.
如果你看看我身后，你刚才描述的确实是我。而且我热爱咖啡壶。那太有趣了。
Are you serious?
你说真的吗？
Oh, my god, that's my favorite. I had my grandmother's four-cup percolator all through vet school. And so my wife and I just bought-- and this is-- we bought a coffee pot. We needed to get new stuff. And I bought a 12-cup percolator. And I just can't master it the way I had that 4-cup.
天哪，那是我的最爱。我在兽医学院期间一直用我祖母的四杯份咖啡壶。所以我和妻子刚买了……这很巧……我们买了一个咖啡壶。我们需要买新的东西。我买了一个12杯份的。我就是没法像当年用那个4杯份的那样掌握好火候。
So all those things I thought-- ranch, check. Cabin, check. Coffee percolator, check. Flannel, check. Motorcycle-- I'm going to say double check because he goes on long rides alone in the desert. Horses-- OK, no horses. But he has worked as a wrangler in Montana. And watching the sunrise from his porch-- well, his porch face is west, not east.
所以所有我想到的——牧场，没错。木屋，没错。咖啡壶，没错。法兰绒，没错。摩托车——我得说再加个正确，因为他确实会独自在沙漠里进行长途骑行。马……好吧，没有马。但他确实在蒙大拿州当过牧马人。至于从门廊看日出——嗯，他的门廊是朝西的，不是朝东。
And so not sunrise-- they're close-- but sunset is my big thing. And I have a sunset tune, released by Pearl Jam. Sunsets here are incredible, right over that ridge, right there.
所以不是日出——虽然它们很接近——但我最喜欢的是日落。我有一首“日落曲”，是珍珠果酱乐队出的。这儿的日落令人难以置信，就在那个山脊上方。
Oh, my god, yeah, you're pointing--
天哪，是的，你指的地方——
They are absolutely incredible.
它们简直太不可思议了。
And again, I don't know quite how to say this professionally, but this entire gazing up on the snow-kissed ridge thing-- as a reporter, I can report that is an objectively hot scenario.
再次重申，我不知道如何从职业角度来表达，但这整个“凝视白雪覆盖的山脊”的情景——作为一名记者，我可以报道说，这在客观上是一个很火的场景。
Yeah, I laughed when they said that because I was like, that's not how anyone lives. But as I'm looking out, you're pointing at snow-covered mountains. And this is a log cabin and a porch.
是的，他们说这话时我笑了，因为我觉得那是没人会过的生活。但当我看向窗外，你指着白雪皑皑的山峰，这是一个木屋和一个门廊。
Yeah, yeah. And the reservoir's right there. It is absolutely amazing, absolutely amazing.
没错，没错。水库就在那边。这绝对是令人惊叹的，绝对令人惊叹。
I was honestly floored that they got it so close. To me, that had seemed like the least likely possible outcome of all of this. Though to everyone in town, he was a fantasy person. So they invented a life that was perfect enough for this perfect person, which of course, left so much out. For instance, Dr. Artz is funny. And he likes dorky things, like Waiting for Guffman and Monty Python, which he quotes freely and regularly.
老实说，我没想到他们竟然猜得这么准，这让我感到震撼。对我而言，这看起来是所有可能性中几率最小的结局。不过对镇上的每个人来说，他是一个幻想中的人物，所以他们虚构了一个对这个完美人物而言足够完美的人生，当然这也省去了很多细节。例如，阿茨医生很幽默。而且他喜欢书呆子气的东西，比如《等待古夫曼》和《蒙提·派森》，他经常随口引用。
And we will call him Tim.
而我们将称他为蒂姆。
Tim.
蒂姆。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
See?
看见没？
Also, no one in town knew the most important thing in his life right now, which is that he's leaving. When I talked to him, he already had his house almost entirely packed up. He hadn't told many clients yet. But his wife and three dogs were already gone. He's moving back to Pittsburgh, his hometown. His mom's getting older. And he didn't like her being alone so much. In fact, they just had a scare. And he was about to get on a red eye.
而且，镇上没人知道他生命中最重要的事情，那就是他要离开了。当我跟他交谈时，他的房子几乎已经全打包好了。他还没告诉多少客户。但他的妻子和三条狗已经走了。他要搬回匹兹堡，他的家乡。他妈妈年纪大了。他不希望她一个人住太久。事实上，他们刚经历了一次惊吓。他正准备搭乘夜班机回去。
Luckily-- I thought I was going straight to the hospital. But my mom-- my wife's with her right now. They discharged her. So I'll probably just go over and say, hi, Mom, and fall asleep on her chair-- in her chair or something.
幸运的是……我本以为我要直接去医院。但我妈……我妻子现在正陪着她。他们给她办了出院。所以我可能直接过去说声“妈，我回来了”，然后在她的椅子上睡着。
Are you guys close?
你们关系很亲近吗？
Oh, very. Yes. I want to move home as much as possible, as soon as possible, because my mother-- she's 88. So you've got to take every day. I want to be there every day I possibly can.
噢，非常亲近。是的。我希望能尽快搬回家，因为我的母亲……她已经88岁了。所以你必须珍惜每一天。我希望每天都能陪在她身边。
Before I left, I asked him the question so many people in town had asked me. Does Dr. Artz have a Dr. Artz? Does he do this too? And he was very polite, and tried so hard to say yes, really tried to put me at ease and say that I wasn't a weirdo, that no one in town was a creep, that it's totally human and that of course he does this. But the only example he could come up with was this.
在我离开前，我问了他那个镇上很多人问过我的问题。阿茨医生有他自己的“阿茨医生”吗？他也会这么做吗？他非常有礼貌，极力想说是的，他真的努力让我感到轻松，说我不是怪胎，镇上的人也不是变态，这完全是人之常情，他当然也会这么做。但他能想出的唯一例子只有这个。
I remember just me and my buddy talking. And we got fixated on some guy's belt. I think he was wearing a belt in a hot tub. And so--
我记得我和哥们儿聊天。我们盯着某人的皮带看了半天。我想他在热水浴缸里戴着皮带。所以——
He was wearing a belt in a hot tub?
他在热水浴缸里戴着皮带？
You know, like shorts. Maybe he didn't have a bathing suit. So he had a belt on with his shorts. And we-- literally, it was a half hour, talking about when he bought that belt and what that belt meant to him. And then the story went way beyond that belt.
你知道，就像短裤。也许他没带泳裤。所以他穿着短裤戴着皮带。我们……真的，我们足足讨论了半小时他是何时买的那条皮带，那条皮带对他意味着什么。然后故事的发展远远超出了那条皮带。
It was a good effort. But I think it's not the same thing. When he's drinking his coffee and staring at the amazing sunset from his cabin, I do not think he's thinking about that guy in the hot tub. Maybe that's the difference between doctor Artz and the rest of us. Some of us spend a lot of time thinking about people we don't know. And some of us are the thought about.
他努力了。但我认为这不一样。当他喝着咖啡，从木屋凝视惊人的日落时，我不认为他在想那个热水浴缸里的人。也许这就是阿茨医生和我们其余人的区别。我们中有些人花大量时间去想那些我们不认识的人。而有些人则是被想的那个人。
Act Two, Who is Sarah Blust? So maybe some of us spend a weird amount of energy thinking about people we barely know. But rarely then, do we go up to those same people and get to know them, and test the reality of whatever fantasy we have of them. But in our next story, that's exactly what happens. It comes from producer Alix Spiegel.
第二幕，谁是莎拉·布拉斯特？也许我们中有些人花在琢磨那些几乎不认识的人身上的精力多得离谱。但很少有人会直接走过去认识他们，去验证我们关于他们的幻想是否真实。但在我们的下一个故事里，情况恰恰如此。这来自于制作人阿莉克斯·斯皮格尔。
This is a little weird. But it's going to be OK.
这有点奇怪。但一切都会好起来的。
It's going to be OK.
一切都会好起来的。
Yeah.
是啊。
It's never easy for me to interview people I'm close to. So usually I try hard to avoid it. But a little while ago, I sat down with one of my dearest friends, Sarah Blust, to talk about something that happened to her when we were younger. A story that I've recently come to see in a totally new way, as not just a story about a strange thing that happened, but also as a good example of the way stories -- the ones we tell about ourselves and others we imagine -- can bend our lives in odd directions.
采访亲近的人对我来说从不容易。所以通常我尽量避免。但不久前，我跟最好的朋友之一莎拉·布拉斯特坐下来，聊了聊她年轻时发生的一件事。一个我最近才以全新视角看待的故事，它不仅是一个关于奇怪巧合的故事，也是一个关于我们讲述的关于自己及想象中他人的故事如何让生活发生奇特转向的绝佳例证。
I was thinking about how this is such a crazy story. But I never, ever thought of it as a story because I just experienced it as--
我在想这真是一个疯狂的故事。但我从没把它当作一个“故事”，因为我只是把它当作……
Our lives.
我们的生活。
--our lives. Yes.
——我们的生活。没错。
I met Sarah my first year of college. We ate at the same place at Oberlin, a small house on campus called Keep. I was immediately drawn to Sarah, I think because I saw her as my opposite. To me, Sarah seemed like a red-headed gush of uncomplicated joy, music, and glitter, a free and easy person who was up for anything.
我和莎拉在大学一年级相识。我们在欧柏林的一家校内小餐馆“Keep”吃饭。我立刻被莎拉吸引，我想是因为我把她看作我的反面。对我来说，莎拉就像一股红发、毫无阻碍的欢乐、音乐和亮片的涌动，一个随意自在、乐于尝试任何事情的人。
I saw myself as the mirror opposite. There was nothing free or easy about me. I was hell bent, so on a mission to remake myself that I was oblivious to many of the parts of college life that preoccupied my peers, including, as Sarah was maybe a little quick to point out, hygiene.
我把自己看作她的镜像反面。我身上一点也没有随意自在。我一心想要重塑自己，以至于忽略了同龄人关注的许多大学生活的部分，包括——正如莎拉可能会很快指出的那样——个人卫生。
You wore the same thing every day.
你每天都穿同一件衣服。
Did I, really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
What did I wear?
我穿了什么？
You wore this brownish sweatshirt that had a lot of holes in it. And you always had a backpack that was full of books because you were always going to the library. And apparently I was always the one who was not square. I was hippie, whatever comes-- whatever happens, happens. I'll go with the flow. And then Alix was like, what the hell are you doing?
你穿的那件棕色运动衫上面有很多洞。而且你总是背着一个装满书的背包，因为你总是要去图书馆。显然我总是那个“不呆板”的人。我是嬉皮士，无论发生什么，顺其自然。随遇而安。然后阿莉克斯就会说，你到底在干什么？
I could not go with the flow, not even a little, because of violin. The short version is that for a variety of reasons, my mother decided, when I was five, that I would become a world-famous solo violinist. But inconveniently for me, world-famous solo violinist is a field which involves ridiculous amounts of practice, three to six hours a day on top of school and homework.
我无法随遇而安，甚至一点都不能，因为小提琴。简而言之，由于多种原因，我母亲在我五岁时决定让我成为世界著名的小提琴独奏家。但对我来说很不凑巧，成为世界顶级小提琴家意味着难以置信的练习量，每天在学校和家庭作业之外还要练习三到六个小时。
I quit as soon as I got to college. But the whole violin thing meant that a sizable portion of my childhood was spent alone, in a practice room, with, as my brother likes to joke, nothing but the cinder blocks for friends.
我一上大学就放弃了。但整个小提琴练习意味着我童年的很大一部分时间都是独自在练习室度过的，就像我哥哥开玩笑说的那样，除了煤渣砖，没有朋友。
And then there was Sarah. The last of three sisters, she'd grown up surrounded by people, and so had this easy way with them. Sarah was the kind of person who would literally brighten at the sight of someone, almost no matter who that person was, I remember thinking. And it felt like fun just inevitably found her.
然后就是莎拉。她是三个姐妹中最小的，从小被人群包围，所以很自然地就有一种与人相处的方式。莎拉是那种见到某人会真正感到欣喜的人，我记得当时心想，几乎不管那个人是谁。而且感觉快乐总是不可避免地找到她。
For example, there was a brief time, in our 30s, when we both lived in New York City. And I remember one random Tuesday, after work, I happened to meet up with Sarah for dinner. And I asked how her day was. Sarah explained what, for her, had been a fairly typical day.
举个例子，三十多岁时我们都住在纽约，有一段短暂的时间。我记得某个随机的周二下班后，我刚好跟莎拉碰面吃晚饭。我问她那天过得怎么样。莎拉描述了她那天其实相当典型的一天。
And though I don't remember the details, I vividly remembered the sentence that went through my head immediately after hearing it. Why do I never end up on a pirate ship in the middle of the Hudson River? During that time period, a sentence like that probably went through my head two out of every five times I talked to Sarah. So I think that's all the Sarah Blust context you need to appreciate the story you're about to hear.
虽然我不记得细节，但我清楚地记得听到后立刻出现在脑海里的一句话：“为什么我从来没在哈德逊河中央的一艘海盗船上结束我的一天？”在那段时间里，像这样的话，我每跟莎拉聊五次天大概会有两次出现在脑子里。所以我想，要欣赏你即将听到的故事，掌握这些莎拉·布拉斯特的背景就够了。
This particular story, I guess, starts at my 10-year reunion. Yeah.
这个特别的故事，我想，是从我的十周年校庆开始的。没错。
In 2004, about 10 years after we graduated, Sarah and a couple of her female friends decided to return to campus for their reunion. They weren't going in an overly-earnest, I miss my college kind of way. I think this was half ironic.
2004年，我们毕业十年后，莎拉和她的几位女性朋友决定回校参加校庆。她们不是那种过于真诚、怀念大学的情怀。我认为这是一半带点反讽的。
And I think somehow, one of us had found out about a party, a party that was being held by actual seniors. And we went.
我想不知怎么地，我们其中一个打听到了一个派对，一个由真正的四年级生举办的派对。我们就去了。
And you went in the spirit of what? Was: it like, we're clowning, we're crashing?
你们是抱着什么心态去的？是说，我们在恶搞，我们在硬闯？
Yeah, I think it was total party crashing. It was also hilarious to be hanging out with, I guess what we thought of as kids, 10 years younger. But it felt so familiar. It's exactly what we wanted because it was like being at Oberlin again. It was that feel.
是啊，我觉得完全是闯入派对。跟我们自认为比我们小十岁的孩子在一起玩也很有趣。但这感觉太熟悉了。这正是我们想要的，因为它就像回到欧柏林一样。就是那种感觉。
So they make their way to this off-campus house where music is blaring and a large number of alcohol-drenched college students are littered across the lawn.
于是她们来到那间校外的房子，音乐震耳欲聋，大量喝得烂醉的大学生散落在草坪上。
And I remember we hung out a lot in the backyard because we felt a little bit out of place. And then finally, we met-- I was hanging out in the house proper. And there was this really fun dance floor happening. I feel like-- it was almost like the crowds parted in a certain way. And this kid, this guy, comes over. And from what I remember, he basically ordered me to dance. It was like, dance floor, now.
我记得我们在后院待了很久，因为我们感觉有点格格不入。最终我们遇到了……我当时在房子里面，那里有一个非常棒的舞池。我感觉……人群似乎以某种方式分开了。有个孩子，有个家伙过来了。据我所知，他基本是命令我跳舞。就像是，“舞池，现在，过来”。
Now this is Sarah Blust, we're talking about.
这里我们说的是莎拉·布拉斯特。
I was not one to say no. So--
我不是那种会拒绝的人。所以——
Besides, this guy, whoever he was, was attractive.
况且，这个家伙，不管他是谁，很有魅力。
He was really cute. And he had dark hair and pretty eyes, and little shorter than me. And definitely a senior.
他真的很可爱。他有深色的头发和漂亮的眼睛，比我矮一点。绝对是四年级生。
What do you mean, definitely a senior?
你为什么说“绝对是四年级生”？
Well, he was certainly a college student. And I think at that point, I was feeling so different because I'd been living in New York City for 10 years and had charted my own way.
嗯，他确实是个大学生。我想那时，我感觉自己与众不同，因为我在纽约住了10年，已经开辟了自己的路。
I don't want you to get the wrong idea about Sarah. She's not the kind of person who typically flirts with random college seniors. Today, she's the director of two sexual and reproductive health clinics in New York. And she was well on her way to becoming the director of two reproductive health clinics by the time of the reunion. So she wasn't exactly itching to take a college kid seriously.
我不希望你对莎拉产生错误的看法。她并不是那种通常会随便跟大学生调情的人。今天，她是纽约两家性与生殖健康诊所的负责人。而在校庆时，她也已经在成为两家生殖健康诊所负责人的路上了。所以她并不急于认真对待一个大学生。
But wow, he was really super nice. And it's really, really fun. So yeah, so we danced, and danced. And then it was getting to that awkward part of the party, where the beer is gone.
但是哇，他真的超级好。而且真的非常有趣。所以是的，我们跳啊跳。然后派对到了那个尴尬的部分，啤酒喝光了。
Fortunately Dan-- that was the guy's actual name, Dan-- had the foresight to stow an emergency six pack in his room.
幸运的是，丹——那就是那家伙的真名，丹——有远见，在他房间里藏了六瓶急救啤酒。
And so we ended up going up to his room and hanging out. And--
于是我们最后去了他的房间待着。而且——
Discreet fade to black.
画面转暗。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, so then what happened?
好的，然后发生了什么？
So then the morning came. It was brutal. I was totally hung over. And we couldn't dally because his parents were about to arrive because it was his graduation. So we're getting it all together preparing to get out the house.
然后早上来了。那简直惨不忍睹。我彻底宿醉了。而且我们不能耽搁，因为他父母快要到了，因为是他的毕业典礼。所以我们收拾东西准备离开那间房子。
And yeah, and then at a certain point he said, so Sarah, what's your last name, which was kind of funny because we had spent all this time together. But right, he was Dan. I was Sarah. We didn't know anything else, really, about each other.
然后是的，就在某个点他说，莎拉，你姓什么？这挺有趣的，因为我们在一起待了这么久。但是没错，他是丹。我是莎拉。我们真的对彼此一无所知。
And so I said Blust. Sarah Blust. And he like completely flips. He completely flips out. And I just remember him-- he did this thing when he jumped out of bed. And he was like, oh, my god, oh, my god, oh, my god.
我说，布拉斯特。莎拉·布拉斯特。他就像彻底崩溃了。他彻底疯了。我只记得他……他做了一个动作，从床上跳起来。他说，噢，天哪，噢，天哪，噢，天哪。
I thought, did I just sleep with my brother?
我在想，我是不是跟我哥哥睡了？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I'm like, am I related because he hears my last name and he freaks out. So I'm like, what is going on?
我在想，我们有血缘关系吗？因为他听到我的姓氏就吓坏了。所以我在想，到底发生了什么？
It felt like the room had tilted, like just the world had just tilted all of a sudden.
感觉房间仿佛倾斜了，就像世界突然倾斜了。
This, of course, is Dan, the cute, kind senior who lured my friend, Sarah, to his room with promises of Pabst Blue Ribbon. He confirms that when he first heard the name Sarah Blust, he pretty much lost his mind and started screaming at the top of his lungs.
当然，这就是丹，那个可爱、善良、用百威啤酒的承诺诱骗我朋友莎拉去他房间的四年级生。他证实，当他第一次听到莎拉·布拉斯特这个名字时，他确实差不多疯了，并开始竭尽全力尖叫。
And I'm like, Sarah, you're not going to believe this. You're not going to believe this. I have to tell you this story, the story within the story.
我说，莎拉，你不会相信这件事的。你绝对不会相信。我必须给你讲这个故事，故事里的故事。
Dan's story starts at Keep Cottage, the same place I met Sarah my first year at Oberlin. Dan, as a freshman, had lived there too. And he says one day, he was hanging out in the lounge, on the ground floor.
丹的故事始于Keep小屋，也就是我大一认识莎拉的地方。丹作为新生也曾住在那里。他说有一天，他在一楼的休息室消磨时间。
And there were bookshelves. And on the bookshelves were old photo albums, old books, old textbooks that people had left behind.
那里有书架。书架上有旧相册、旧书、人们留下的旧教科书。
So Dan picks up one of the photo albums.
于是丹拿起其中一本相册。
These were all people who had lived in Keep before, some time in the distant past. And I was just flipping through and just looking at them, and just started to wonder what their lives were like. Did they do the same thing that I was doing then, like sitting in the lounge and waiting for people to come and distract them?
这些都是过去在Keep住过的人，很久以前。我只是翻看着，好奇他们的人生是什么样的。他们是否也做着我当时做的事，比如坐在休息室等别人来打扰他们？
All those other lives-- what were those other people like?
所有那些人生……那些人是什么样的？
There was one photograph that stuck out to me. And I can't say-- I never really could put my finger on why that particular photo stuck out to me. But it was a girl, looking a little bit, maybe, dazed, in the foreground, and a guy, sitting on a bed, not looking at the camera, in the background. And I said, I want to know who this person is. I wonder what her life was like.
有一张照片吸引了我。我无法说出……我也从没真正搞清为什么那张照片吸引我。但那是一个女孩，看起来有点，也许，迷茫，在前景里；而背景里有一个男人坐在床上，没看镜头。我说，我想知道这个人是谁。我好奇她的人生是什么样的。
Luckily, the photo contained additional information. There was a name on the back.
幸运的是，照片里包含了额外的信息。背面有一个名字。
Sarah Blust.
莎拉·布拉斯特。
So I pulled the photograph out of the photo album. I brought it upstairs. And I sat down at my computer. And instead of doing my homework, I wrote a brief, short story, a one-page story, about the person in the photograph.
于是我把照片从相册里抽了出来。带到了楼上。坐在电脑前。没写作业，而是写了一篇短篇小说，一篇关于照片中人的单页故事。
I know this sounds a little unusual. It is a little unusual. But Dan made up a whole fictional story about a redhead named Sarah Blust, someone with two sisters, like the real Sarah Blust, who, like the real Sarah, goes to college and maybe smokes a little too much weed.
我知道这听起来有点不寻常。确实有点不寻常。但丹编造了一整个关于名叫莎拉·布拉斯特的红发女孩的虚构故事，一个像真实的莎拉·布拉斯特一样有两个姐妹的人，她像真实的莎拉一样去上大学，也许抽了太多的草。
Now Dan hadn't seen this story since graduation. But we were actually able to retrieve a copy from the carcass of his 20-year-old candy-blue Apple computer, due to the superhuman efforts of a San Francisco-based computer expert named Mitch. Thanks, Mitch.
丹自从毕业后就没再见过这个故事。但我们居然能在他的那台20年前的糖果色苹果电脑残骸里找回了一份拷贝，这得归功于一位名叫米奇的旧金山电脑专家的超人努力。谢谢你，米奇。
Anyway, the main focus of Dan's story is Sarah's involvement with this fictional guy named Matt. Throughout the story, Sarah and Matt circle each other, drawn, but not quite sure what to make of the strange connection they feel. And in the end, they don't end up together. In Dan's imagination, it's this made-up character, Matt, who takes the photo that he found. Here's the last paragraph.
总之，丹故事的核心是莎拉与一个叫马特的虚构人物的纠葛。在整个故事中，莎拉和马特相互环绕，被彼此吸引，却不确定这种奇妙的连接意味着什么。最后，他们没有在一起。在丹的想象中，正是这个叫马特的虚构角色拍下了他发现的那张照片。这是最后一段。
"Two weeks before the school year broke into summer vacation, Matt came and knocked on Sarah's door in Keep. He brought with him this picture, and gave it to her. That day, he told her that he really cared about her and wanted to see her more often. She held on to the picture all summer, keeping it as a memento of Matt and her tragic love. She did not realize this picture was in storage when she moved out. She now and then thinks of Matt on her way to work or when playing with the kids. She wonders where this picture is. Little does she know, it is on the wall of Keep Cottage."
“在学年进入暑假前两周，马特去Keep敲了莎拉的门。他带来了这张照片，送给了她。那天，他告诉她他真的很在乎她，希望能多见见她。她整个夏天都留着这张照片，把它当作马特和他们凄美爱情的纪念品。她没意识到搬家时这张照片被存在了储物间里。她偶尔会在去上班或者跟孩子们玩耍时想起马特。她好奇这张照片在哪儿。她没想到的是，它就在Keep小屋的墙上。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Oh, my god. That is insane.
噢，我的天。这简直太疯了。
Had you ever done anything like that before? Or was there something in this person, in this photo?
你以前做过类似的事吗？还是照片里的这个人有什么特别之处？
Hmm. At the time, it really felt like a random act, like I was just doing something to amuse myself at random.
嗯。当时真的感觉像是一个随机举动，就像我只是随便做点什么来逗自己开心。
And Dan didn't just write a story about Sarah Blust. He also posted said story, of Sara Blust, with her photo, on the door of his room, where it stayed until the end of the school year, at which point, Dan says, it went into a trash can. And he never, ever thought of it again.
而且丹不只是写了关于莎拉·布拉斯特的故事。他还把这个故事以及莎拉·布拉斯特的照片贴在了自己房门上，直到学年末，丹说，它被扔进了垃圾桶。而且他再也没有，绝对没有再想过它。
At all, until commencement week, when I met Sarah Blust, who was standing in my room.
一直到毕业周，我见到了莎拉·布拉斯特，她正站在我的房间里。
I was like, you are fucking kidding me.
我说，你在开什么玩笑。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I did not believe a word he was saying. But--
我不相信他说的半个字。但……
Did you actually not believe a word he was saying?
你真的不相信他说的半个字吗？
I could believe it but it just-- I wasn't believing it. I was believing it and not at the same time, if that's possible. And he said no, it's real. And he pulls out his laptop. And he opens it up. And he points to this file that has my name on it.
我可以相信，但这只是……我不愿意相信。我既相信又不相信，如果这可能的话。他说不，这是真的。他拿出笔记本电脑。打开，指向那个写着我名字的文件。
And I almost lost my mind. How is it possible that you meet someone for the first time, and they have a story about you, a file with your name on it?
我差点疯了。怎么可能第一次见某人，而他们手里有关于你的故事，一个写着你名字的文件？
On their computer.
在他们的电脑里。
On their computer. What is that?
在他们的电脑里。那是什么？
Now I want to pause for a second because what I'm interested in is the stories people tell themselves. So I want to map their stories at each stage. For Dan, what had happened between him and Sarah the night before his graduation was very unambiguous. This was solid, one-night-stand territory. Yes, he had asked for Sarah's last name. But it wasn't for particularly sentimental reasons.
现在我想暂停一下，因为我感兴趣的是人们对自己讲述的故事。所以我想在每个阶段映射他们的故事。对丹来说，毕业前夜发生在他和莎拉之间的事非常明确。这完全是“一夜情”范畴。是的，他确实问了莎拉的姓。但这并不是出于特别的情感原因。
Was it just like, I have to be a gentleman, I should know both of the names of the women I sleep with? Or was it, I'm going to stalk her so last names would be helpful.
是那种“我必须表现得绅士，我应该知道我睡过的女性的名字”吗？还是说，“我要去跟踪她，所以知道姓氏会有帮助”。
I thought, maybe we can hang out again and--
我想，也许我们可以再见个面，然后……
Maybe you can get lucky twice.
也许你可以梅开二度？
Exactly.
确实如此。
Sarah felt the exact same way. She thought, very reasonably, that Dan was incredibly young and had a lot of growing to do. So thank you, no thank you.
莎拉感觉完全一样。她非常合理地认为，丹实在太年轻了，还有很多成长空间。所以谢谢，不用了。
Dan had post-graduation plans. The kind of post-graduation plans parents approve of, about maybe going to medical school and becoming a doctor, and-- oh, yeah, that's right. He had a gig starting in the fall.
丹有毕业后的计划。那种父母会赞同的计划，关于也许去医学院当个医生，而且……噢，没错。他在秋天有一份工作等着。
Well, I was going to go into the Peace Corps and do public-health work. I had been assigned to go to Central Asia.
嗯，我本来打算去和平队做公共卫生工作。我被指派去中亚。
Were you excited about that plan?
你对那个计划感到兴奋吗？
I was. I was very excited about that plan.
我很兴奋。我非常期待那个计划。
But on the car ride home, Dan started thinking about what had happened. Objectively, it was just crazy. Dan only had scraps of information about this person, Sarah Blust, this person he had first imagined when he was a freshman, staring at her photo.
但在回家的车程中，丹开始思考发生了什么。从客观上讲，这简直疯狂。丹只掌握了这个人的只言片语，关于莎拉·布拉斯特，那个他在大一盯着照片时最初想象的人。
He knew that she was in public health, as was he, she was a good dancer, as was he. And he took these scraps, and as we inevitably do, started weaving them into a story, a new story, one with an impressive series of coincidences that, when you stepped back, did look a lot like fate.
他知道她从事公共卫生，他也一样；她是个好舞者，他也一样。他利用这些碎片，像我们不可避免会做的那样，开始编织一个故事，一个新故事，一个有着一系列惊人巧合的故事，当你退后一步看，它确实看起来很像命运。
I remember there was this-- I remember that the sun was setting. And I was driving into the sunset. And the thought just entered-- occurred to me. I was like, I'm going the wrong way. I need to drop out of the Peace Corps and move to New York.
我记得当时……我记得夕阳正在落下。我正朝着夕阳开车。那个念头就出现了。我心想，我走错方向了。我得退出和平队，搬去纽约。
I have to go and see this woman?
我必须去见这个女人？
Yeah.
没错。
Now I don't want to seem like I'm judging Dan for changing the whole course of his life based on what was really pretty slim evidence plus one coincidence. I understand the lure of the story he was taken with. And I, myself, obsessively tell stories as a way to navigate the world. I'm the queen of hopeful projection.
我不想显得我在评判丹，因为基于那些其实相当单薄的证据加上一个巧合就改变了整个人生轨迹。我理解他被这种故事吸引的诱惑。我也一样，强迫性地讲述故事作为导航世界的方式。我是“充满希望的投影”女王。
This strange, feverish storytelling started when I was young, a habit I picked up in the practice room as a way to escape. I would walk in little circles and make up stories about myself and other people. In college, I did this almost every day. I'd walk in little circles for hours, usually until my legs ached.
这种奇特、狂热的讲故事方式始于我年轻时，是我在练习室养成的习惯，作为一种逃避。我会走小圈圈，编造关于自己和他人的故事。在大学里，我几乎每天都这么做。我会走几个小时的小圈，通常直到腿酸。
Like Dan, I was extrapolating from what really happened to what I hoped would happen in the future. Say I'd have some small encounter. Maybe a teacher would offer a kind word. Maybe a boy would nod in my direction. And my imagination would take it from there, build a whole life on those scraps. In my mind, I'd visualize the look of the teacher as they offered me the selective internship that would lead to a dazzling career in public policy or law or, for a very brief period during my senior year, silk screening.
像丹一样，我从实际发生的事情推演到我希望未来发生的事情。假设我遇到一些小插曲。也许老师说了句亲切的话。也许男孩对我点了个头。我的想象力就会接手，在那些碎片上建立整个生命。在脑海中，我会形象化老师递给我那份选择性实习机会的样子，那将引领我走向公共政策或法律的辉煌职业生涯，或者在大四那年的短暂期间，丝网印刷。
Of course, I always kept this little-circles habit secret from everyone. I was aware it was not normal behavior. The one person who knew about it was Sarah. When we lived together in college, she accidentally discovered it.
当然，我一直对所有人保密这种小圈圈习惯。我知道这不是正常的行为。唯一知道的人就是莎拉。我们在大学住在一起时，她意外发现了。
I was probably reading a book or doing some homework. And I heard this creak, creak, creak. And it was just over and over and over and over again. And it took me a while to realize what it was. And then I realized it was you.
我当时可能在看书或写作业。我听到了吱呀、吱呀、吱呀的声音。那是没完没了的。我花了一段时间才意识到那是什么。然后我意识到那一定是你。
But Sarah didn't seem to mind, didn't seem to think I was a freak at all. In fact, the opposite.
但莎拉似乎并不介意，似乎完全没觉得我是个怪胎。事实上，恰恰相反。
I don't know, personally, I found it really endearing. Yeah.
我不知道，就我个人而言，我觉得这很可爱。没错。
Thing is, as I've gotten older, I've grown more wary of this kind of storytelling, conscious of how often the stories we tell ourselves lead us down the wrong path.
问题是，随着年龄增长，我开始对这种叙事保持警惕，意识到我们对自己讲述的故事有多频繁地将我们引入歧途。
I remember that the sun was setting. And I was driving into the sunset. And the thought just entered-- occurred to me. I was like, I'm going the wrong way.
我记得当时……我记得夕阳正在落下。我正朝着夕阳开车。那个念头就出现了。我心想，我走错方向了。
What happened with Dan and Sarah, the wild serendipity of it, gave it the silhouette of one of the most popular stories in American life, the fated love story. I think the fated love story, and the idea that romantic love is the one relationship that can fulfill you, has a unique weight and primacy. It's the kind of story that displaces other stories, easily sweeps them aside, which is what happened with Dan.
丹和莎拉身上发生的事，那种狂野的机缘巧合，赋予了它美国生活中最受欢迎的故事之一——“命定爱情故事”的剪影。我认为命定爱情故事，以及浪漫爱情是唯一能让你满足的关系的想法，有着独特的重量和首要地位。这种故事很容易置换其他故事，轻松将它们扫向一边，这也正是发生在丹身上的事。
He dropped out of the Peace Corps, drove to New York, and instead of working in public health, got a job at the Stereo Exchange in Manhattan. On his way to this unglamorous new life, he wrote Sarah an email, framing his new plan in the most casual, non-threatening, just happened to be dropping everything and moving to your city way possible.
他退出了和平队，开车去了纽约，而不是在公共卫生领域工作，而是在曼哈顿的立体声音响交易所找了份工作。在他前往这个平庸新生活的路上，他给莎拉写了封邮件，以尽可能随意、无威胁、只是正好放弃一切搬去你城市的口吻来规划他的新计划。
Sarah responded with, whoa, that's a lot. Not sure about that. Dan then responded, understand. Seems reasonable. I'm aware I don't really know you. All I'm saying is that we should go on some dates. See what happens.
莎拉回应说，哇，那太多了。不确定那是不是个好主意。丹回应说，理解。看起来很合理。我知道我其实并不了解你。我只是想说，我们应该去约会几次。看看会发生什么。
Sarah told me about all of this at the time. And honestly, I was pro. She'd had a string of boyfriends who didn't seem like good partner material. And I could tell right away that Dan was solid, which from the perspective of the anxious friend, was a relief. Sarah also saw that Dan was a good guy with good values. And she thought he was fun. But she obviously had real reservations.
莎拉当时告诉了我这些。老实说，我很赞成。她交往过一系列看起来不像合适伴侣对象的男友。我立刻就能看出丹很靠谱，从焦虑朋友的角度来看，这是一种解脱。莎拉也看出丹是个价值观端正的好人。而且她觉得他很有趣。但她显然有真正的保留意见。
I liked him a lot. I felt like there was this really incredible connection. But I was also terrified that I had this responsibility for changing someone's life so drastically.
我很喜欢他。我觉得我们之间有一种非常不可思议的连接。但我同时也感到惊恐，因为我有一种责任感，要如此剧烈地改变某个人的人生。
Did it feel like he was actually seeing you? Or did you feel like, you don't even know who I-- this is just a projection?
他感觉是在真正地看着你吗？还是你觉得，你根本不了解我是谁——这只是你的投射？
I think it was both. I think it was both. Yeah, I think I thought that he didn't really know what he was getting into.
我觉得两者皆有。我觉得两者皆有。是的，我想我也觉得他根本不知道自己卷入了什么。
Particularly, what he was getting into in one significant way. Sarah was past 30 and was very clear she wanted children.
特别是，他卷入的有一点很明显。莎拉已经30多岁了，非常清楚地想要孩子。
I was in this moment of thinking about kids, I suppose. And so I had-- I couldn't believe that I could enter into a relationship with someone just coming out of college. But there was a real understanding that the two of us had with each other.
我当时处于考虑孩子的时刻，我想。所以……我无法相信自己能跟一个刚出校门的人建立关系。但我们彼此之间确实有一种真正的理解。
Dan hadn't been planning on having kids so early. But he had been planning on having kids. And he felt like the most important thing was to find the right partner. And if that turned out to be Sarah, he was game. So they decided to go on some dates.
丹原本没打算这么早要孩子。但他确实打算要孩子。他觉得最重要的事情是找到合适的伴侣。如果那个人恰好是莎拉，那他干了。所以他们决定去约会几次。
Their first was a bar in Red Hook that Sarah picked. Then there was the date at the roller rink, where Dan broke out what they both agree were truly killer moves. They had this comfortable vibe. And it was really easy to talk. Really, there was just one problem with this whole situation for Dan.
第一次是在红钩区一家莎拉挑选的酒吧。然后是在轮滑场的一次约会，丹展示了他俩都同意是真正的杀手级动作。他们有一种舒适的气氛。谈话真的很轻松。真的，对丹来说，整个情况只有一个问题。
You see, Sarah Blust, like the rest of us, was nursing her own romantic story. And the other person she was imagining didn't look anything like Dan because her hopes centered so squarely on music.
你知道，莎拉·布拉斯特，和我们其他人一样，正在酝酿她自己的浪漫故事。而她想象中的另一个人长得一点也不像丹，因为她的希望如此明确地聚焦在音乐上。
Music has always been critical to Sarah. She plays the drums, but also guitar, and sings. In fact, music is what brought us together. Our first year of college, we founded an alternative girl band called Succubus, which played all four years. After college, Sarah went on to other bands, many, because music just lights Sarah up.
音乐对莎拉来说一直很关键。她打鼓，也弹吉他、唱歌。事实上，音乐是我们走到一起的原因。大学一年级，我们成立了一个名为“Succubus”的另类女子乐队，玩了四年。大学毕业后，莎拉又加入了其他乐队，很多，因为音乐就是让莎拉点亮的东西。
In your mind, at that time, what was the romantic fantasy that you were imagining?
在你脑海中，那时候，你想象的浪漫幻想是什么？
Oh, it was so sparkly. Being in a band with someone that I loved and play amazing music, and that we would just have this incredible, creative life together.
噢，那是如此闪亮。和一个我深爱的人组乐队，演奏美妙的音乐，我们俩能拥有一段不可思议的、有创造力的生活。
This, of course, is a common romantic fantasy which, like Dan's, "we are fated for each other" fantasy, doesn't always work out well. Unfortunately, for Dan's version of the fantasy, one day, several months after his arrival, Sarah Blust went to a concert, the show of a moderately famous indie band she'd long admired. And the drummer became quite smitten with Sarah, as she was with him.
这当然是一个常见的浪漫幻想，像丹的“我们是命中注定的”幻想一样，并不总是有好结果。不幸的是，对于丹的幻想版本，有一天，在他到来几个月后，莎拉·布拉斯特去参加了一场演唱会，她仰慕已久的一支颇有名气的独立乐队的演出。鼓手被莎拉迷住了，就像她被他迷住一样。
And he pulled me in to a community that I was in awe of, I guess. I was really starstruck.
他把我拉进了一个让我敬畏的圈子里，我想。我真的很崇拜他。
Poor Dan didn't stand a chance. He was science, not music. And the new guy, the drummer, in addition to being closer in age to Sarah, he was just as enthusiastic about their coming future.
可怜的丹一点机会都没有。他是科学，不是音乐。而那个新家伙，鼓手，除了年纪跟莎拉更近，对他们未来的热情也一样高。
He was very much like, we're going to make this happen. He lived in Philadelphia at the time.
他非常像是，“我们要让这一切发生”。他当时住在费城。
Did he moved to New York to be with you too?
他也为了你搬去纽约了？
Yes.
是的。
Oh, my god. Are you fucking kidding me?
噢，我的天。你在开什么玩笑？
No. He moved to New York. And he moved in with me.
没有。他搬到了纽约。而且搬来跟我住在一起了。
Oh, shit. I totally somehow missed that. Wait a second. So you had two people moved to New York for you?
噢，该死。我怎么完全错过了这一点。等等。所以有两个人为你搬到了纽约？
I guess so.
我想是吧。
How come nobody ever moves to New York for me?
为什么从来没人为了我搬去纽约？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Put it another way, why do I never end up on a pirate ship in the middle of the Hudson River?
换句话说，为什么我从来没在哈德逊河中央的一艘海盗船上结束我的一天？
In the interest of journalistic transparency, I will tell you that I was extremely and correctly anti drummer from the beginning. I was firmly team Dan. I made this case to Sarah repeatedly, as is my practice. But in that moment, she was too taken by the story that she carried in her head.
出于新闻透明度的考虑，我要告诉你，我从一开始就是极端且正确地反对鼓手的。我坚定地站在丹这一队。我反复向莎拉陈述这一点，这是我的习惯。但在那个时刻，她被自己脑海中的故事迷住了。
--kind of musician partner that I was supposed to be with, that was just getting in the way of me appreciating Dan. Yeah. I guess I just wasn't feeling it. I guess I just wasn't feeling it.
……那种我应该与之在一起的音乐人伴侣，这正好阻碍了我去欣赏丹。是啊。我想我就是没那种感觉。
I just remember there was a fading out. I think she had a boy-- she got a-- had a boyfriend. That made it pretty clear.
我只记得后来淡出了。我想她有了男友……她有了个男友。这让一切变得很明确。
After about a year of hanging out on the sidelines, Dan gave up and moved on. Eventually he did become a doctor. Today he's a professor of medicine. He specializes in HIV and AIDS.
在旁观了大约一年后，丹放弃并继续前行了。最终他成为了一名医生。今天他是医学教授。他专注于艾滋病和HIV。
20 years on, it's clear that the story he constructed on his ride home from college wasn't true. But he says, in that story, he discovered a useful lesson that he carried forward, and that shaped, he says, his behavior when he finally met his wife.
20年后，很清楚，他在大学回家的路上构思的那个故事不是真的。但他表示，在那个故事中，他发现了一个有用的教训，并将其带入了未来的生活，这塑造了他——他说——在最终遇到妻子时的行为方式。
I think part of what I had learned from my experience with Sarah was that you can build this whole fantasy world about someone, have these romantic ideas. And then reality can be very different. And I think that was something I had learned, and learned to be cautious of in myself.
我认为从我跟莎拉的经历中学到的部分是，你可以关于某人建立整个幻想世界，拥有这些浪漫想法。然后现实可能大不相同。我认为那是我想到的，并学会了在自己身上保持谨慎的东西。
Do you have any regrets?
你有什么遗憾吗？
No.
没有。
Do you ever think of Sarah? Do you ever think, oh, maybe that could have worked under slightly different circumstances?
你会想莎拉吗？你会想，噢，也许在稍微不同的情况下那行得通？
Not really, not since I met my wife.
不怎么想，自从我遇到妻子之后。
As for Sarah, like Dan, she's married and has a beautiful kid, with the same red hair and joy as his mother. But she'll tell you, straight up, that there were moments during her single life when she really regretted that she didn't see the great person standing in front of her.
至于莎拉，像丹一样，她结婚了，有一个漂亮的孩子，带着和他母亲一样的红发和喜悦。但她会直截了当地告诉你，在她单身生活中，确实有那么些时刻她非常后悔没看到眼前这个伟大的人。
She says she saw Dan as this 23-year-old kid, but now feels like he was actually probably more mature than she was. In fact, she's kind of like the Sarah Blust in the story that Dan wrote before they met. That Sarah Blust didn't end up with the guy from Keep, but every once in a while, remembers him.
她说她那时把丹看作一个23岁的孩子，但现在觉得他可能比她当时更成熟。事实上，她有点像丹在他们相遇前写的故事里的那个莎拉·布拉斯特。那个莎拉·布拉斯特没能跟那个Keep里的家伙在一起，但偶尔会想起他。
What's the thing that you learned from this? Or what is the-- yeah.
你从中吸取了什么？或者说……是啊。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, I think that when you're presented, in life, with something that seems like a gift, even if you have other preconceived notions, maybe you're wrong. The story that I was telling myself about who my perfect partner should be or would be, that wasn't really a story that was helpful to me.
嗯，我想当你生活中被呈现出某种看起来像礼物的东西时，即使你有其他先入为主的观念，也许你错了。我对自己讲述的关于完美伴侣应该是谁或会是谁的故事，并不是真正有用的故事。
I guess that's the cue for sad music to play. But on the other hand, isn't that also a story that might not be true? Maybe if Sarah had chosen Dan, I'd be here telling you a different version, one where Dan, confronted with the reality of actual babies in his 20s, bolts the scene. That's the whole damn thing about stories though, isn't it? You can never tell if one is true or not. And there's always a new one beckoning.
我想那是悲伤音乐响起的提示。但换句话说，那不也是一个可能并非真实的故事吗？也许如果莎拉选择了丹，我会在这里告诉你另一个版本，一个在丹20多岁时面对现实中真正婴儿的场景时，落荒而逃的故事。但这正是关于故事的全部该死的地方，不是吗？你永远无法判断哪一个是真的。而且永远有新的故事在招手。
But here's the thing. I am the one who is telling this story. So I can tell it however I want. And I don't want to end it with a sad soundtrack because as Sarah would tell you, she doesn't feel sad. Sarah's soundtrack is punk and pop and marching bands and lullabies and sure, some sad core. But every life has some sad core.
但重点是，我是那个讲述这个故事的人。所以我可以随心所欲地讲述。我不希望用悲伤的配乐结束它，因为正如莎拉会告诉你的，她并不感到悲伤。莎拉的配乐是朋克、流行、行军乐队和摇篮曲，当然，还有一些“悲伤核”。但每个人的人生都有一些悲伤的核心。
Speaking of music, I'll leave you with this, a song from the back catalog of Succubus, the band Sarah and I started our freshman year. She played the drums with her eyes closed. I played a green electric guitar. Together, we blazed a trail of punk-rock glory across North Central Ohio.
说到音乐，我给你们留下这个，来自Succubus乐队的过往目录，那是莎拉和我大一创立的乐队。她闭着眼睛打鼓。我弹绿色的电吉他。我们一起在俄亥俄州中北部留下了一道朋克摇滚荣耀的足迹。
Alix Spiegel, she's a producer on our show.
阿莉克斯·斯皮格尔，我们节目的制作人。
Coming up, strangers come into your house, look at all your stuff, size you up. They think they know you. How close can they get? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，陌生人走进你的房子，查看你所有的东西，评估你。他们以为他们了解你。他们能有多近？一会儿回来，来自芝加哥公共电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Lilly Sullivan, sitting in for Ira Glass. Our show today, The Lives of Others, stories about when you find yourself thinking about people you barely know or don't know at all.
这里是《美国生活》。我是莉莉·沙利文，代班艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目《他人的生活》，讲述当你发现自己不由自主地想念那些你几乎不认识或完全不认识的人时，会发生什么。
In putting together this week's show, I was thinking a lot about the film, The Lives of Others, a movie about East Berlin before the fall of the Berlin Wall. It's about a Stasi agent, whose job it is to spy on a playwright.
在制作本周节目时，我想到很多关于电影《窃听风暴》，一部关于柏林墙倒塌前东柏林电影。讲述了一名史塔西特工的任务是监视一名剧作家。
[SPEAKING GERMAN].
[德语对话]。
For most of it, you watch the Stasi agent, whose life is bare, austere, alone, as he listens in on the life of this playwright, whose life is full of art, beauty, sadness. You watch the agent, in headphones, eavesdropping on the apartment he's bugged. He reads the book the playwright reads, listens to the most personal conversations with his girlfriend. And he starts to become moved by the playwright's life.
在大部分时间里，你注视着史塔西特工，他的生活贫乏、简朴、孤独，他窃听着剧作家的生活，剧作家的生活充满艺术、美和悲伤。你看着那个特工，戴着耳机，在他窃听的公寓里监听。他读剧作家读的书，听他与女友最私密的谈话。然后他开始被剧作家的人生打动。
The agent, who you always see listening in alone, in a dark room, comes to care for the writer, to the point where he eventually tries to protect him. What I remember most about the film is the ache, the sense of longing, and the distances there always are between people. But then there are these moments where there can be this portal of emotion from your life to someone else's.
那个你总是看到独自在黑暗房间里监听的特工，开始关心那个作家，以至于他最终尝试保护他。关于这部电影我记忆最深的是那种阵痛、那种渴望感，以及人与人之间永远存在的距离。但有时会有一些时刻，可以有这种从你的生命通往他人生命的各种情绪窗口。
There are other jobs where thinking about someone else's life is just built into it. We're wondering what that's like in jobs with much lower stakes than being a government spy, like pet sitting That's what act Three's about. One of our other producers here, Aviva DeKornfeld, realized pet sitting is a job just like that. She talked to a dozen pet sitters, who confirmed it, and has this story about two of them. We're calling this act, If These Dogs Could Talk. Here's Aviva.
还有其他职业是把思考他人生活内置其中的。我们想知道在比成为政府间谍低得多的职业中这会是什么样子，比如宠物看护。这就是第三幕的内容。我们这里的另一位制作人阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德意识到宠物看护正是那样一种工作。她采访了十几位宠物看护，证实了这一点，并带来了关于其中两个人的故事。我们将这一幕称为《如果这些狗会说话》。这是阿维瓦。
With most jobs, you have some sort of relationship with the person you work for. You see them in the office or wherever it is you work. But pet sitting is one of the few jobs where you're only there if the other person isn't there. The job is to cosplay as the pet owner.
大多数工作，你和你服务的对象有一定的关系。你在办公室或不管你在哪儿工作的地方见到他们。但宠物看护是为数不多只有当对方不在场时你才在那里的工作之一。这项工作就是去扮演宠物主人。
Yeah, most of them have me sleep in their beds because they want the routine of, wherever the dogs sleep, they want me to sleep with them. So I'm sleeping in their beds, in their bedroom. I'm cooking in their kitchen. I'm messing with all the algorithms on their streaming services.
是啊，他们大多数让我睡在他们的床上，因为他们想要那种惯例，不管狗在哪儿睡，他们想要我和它们一起睡。所以我睡在他们的床上，他们的卧室里。我在他们的厨房里做饭。我摆弄他们流媒体服务上的所有算法。
This is L. She started pet sitting a couple of years ago. And she made a point to tell me she never snoops. In fact, she asks people to leave everything she'll need out on the counter so she doesn't have to go looking for anything. But even without snooping, so much of the pet owners private life is so nakedly on display, what they watch on Netflix, what they have on their fridge. You can't help but glean bits of information about the person you're standing in for.
这是L。她几年前开始做宠物看护。她特意告诉我她从不打探隐私。事实上，她让人们把所有她需要的东西留在柜台上，这样她就不用到处去找。但即使不去打探，宠物主人的私生活还是赤裸裸地展示出来，他们看什么网飞，冰箱里有什么。你无法不去搜集一些关于你所替代之人的信息。
There's a young couple. And I think they want to read. They always have the book on both nightstands. But I've never seen either bookmark move. And sometimes the stack of books get higher. But they never go lower.
有一对年轻夫妇。我想他们想读书。他们在两个床头柜上都有书。但我从未见过任何书签移动。有时书堆变得更高。但它们从未变低。
L ambiently wonders about all her clients. Mostly she's in it for the dogs. But there was one client, in particular, that she found herself thinking about because her house felt different than the others.
L会漫无目的地好奇她所有的客户。大多时候她是为了狗才做这个的。但有一个特定的客户，她发现自己会去想，因为她家的感觉跟别人不一样。
There were two huge gaming setups so it looked like they either gamed next to each other or with each other. It just felt very copacetic. It felt like they really were suited for each other.
那儿有两台巨大的游戏设置，看起来他们要么坐在彼此旁边玩，要么一起玩。这感觉非常融洽。感觉他们真的很适合彼此。
This togetherness, side-by-side gaming, is not typical. L sat for another couple, where the guy had his music room, the woman, and her crafting table, very separate hobbies. That's way more common, she says. L also like how much this couple seemed to prioritize comfort.
这种亲密感，并排游戏，并不典型。L给另一对夫妇当过看护，那个男的有他的音乐室，女的有她的手工桌，爱好非常分开。她说那更常见。L也喜欢这对夫妇优先考虑舒适度的感觉。
Their sofa was basically just giant pillows, down pillows. So it was just like basically a giant bed. And for me, I was like, oh, that just felt really romantic. They couldn't help but melt into each other.
他们的沙发基本上就是巨大的枕头，羽绒枕。所以那基本上就像一张巨大的床。对我来说，我当时心想，噢，那感觉真的很浪漫。他们不禁融化进彼此之中。
Just to be clear, L's never met the husband, never seen the two of them together. She has no idea what they're like as a couple. But she'd like to imagine them sitting on their big, comfy couch, chatting agreeably, deciding what they wanted to do that day. In L's imagination, arriving at a decision was always easy for them.
说明一下，L从未见过丈夫，也从未见过他们俩在一起。她根本不知道他们作为夫妻是什么样的。但她喜欢想象他们坐在他们那张舒适的大沙发上，愉快地聊天，决定那天要做什么。在L的想象中，达成一致对他们来说总是容易的。
I don't know. It just felt like they agreed on things a lot. And again, I have no proof of that whatsoever. But for me, that's what-- it just seemed like they would look at each other and be like, hey, do you want to do this? And it's like, yes. And it was just known by both parties.
我不知道。感觉他们对事情很能达成一致。再一次，我对此完全没有证据。但对我来说，就是……看起来他们会看着对方说，嘿，你想做这个吗？然后是，是的。双方对此心知肚明。
Did you ever feel jealous of their relationship?
你有没有嫉妒过他们的关系？
Oh, definitely. But this was also right after my divorce. And my ex-husband and I had very different interests. (LAUGHING) My ex left me for a Pilates instructor.
噢，当然。但这刚好是在我离婚后。我前夫和我的兴趣爱好完全不同。（笑）我前夫为了一个普拉提教练抛弃了我。
Oh, god.
噢，天哪。
And I'm not a Pilates gal. So I think for me, it was seeing this couple-- and to be honest, they kind of looked more like me, plus sized. And when she had met with me, and she told me about how they'd been together for like 15 years and met in college-- and so for me, it was just, oh, these people found their person.
我不是那种普拉提女孩。所以我认为对我来说，看到这对夫妇——老实说，他们长得有点像我，大码身材。当她跟我见面时，告诉了我他们在一起大概15年了，大学时相识——所以对我来说，就是，噢，这些人找到了他们的人。
L started dog sitting for this couple about a month after her marriage fell apart. Her ex-husband was a real plastic-on-the-furniture kind of person, definitely not into comfort. She said he never relaxed.
L在婚姻破裂一个月后开始给这对夫妇看狗。她前夫是一个真正的“家具上裹塑料布”那种人，绝对不爱舒适。她说他从不放松。
And for me, the idea of lounging and just relaxing and melting into someone-- yeah, that was definitely something I really craved, especially coming out of that relationship.
对我来说，那种闲逛、放松并融化进某人身边的想法——是的，那绝对是我非常渴望的东西，特别是在结束了那段关系之后。
L would spend days alone in this couple's house, on her own for the first time in over 10 years, like she was in some strange, on-set audition for a life she hoped to have for herself one day. One day, just as L was about to head over to the couple's house to dog sit, she got a text.
L会在这对夫妇的房子里独自待上好几天，十多年来第一次独处，就像她在进行某种奇特的现场试镜，演的是她希望有一天自己能拥有的生活。有一天，就在L准备前往这对夫妇的家去看狗时，她收到了一条短信。
And it was from an unknown number-- because I had never dealt with the husband. And it just said, we no longer need you. We'll still pay you for the week. And that was it. And it was weird to me because he had never-- he and I had never spoken. It was always me and the wife. So to hear from him was odd in general. But then I was just so curt and done.
来自一个未知号码——因为我从未跟那个丈夫打过交道。上面只写着，我们不再需要你了。我们这周还是会付钱给你。就这样。这对我来说很奇怪，因为他……他和我从未说过话。一直都是我和那个妻子。所以听到他这么说很古怪。但我当时太生硬而且结束了。
So what did you think when you got his text?
当你收到他的短信时你想到什么？
My mind started racing because I was like, well, is this-- did someone end up in a car accident? Did something really bad happen? And again, I wasn't going to press because again, it's none of my business. I'm just the help.
我的思绪开始狂奔，因为我在想，嗯，这是……有人出车祸了吗？发生了什么很糟糕的事吗？再一次，我不会追问，因为再一次，那不关我的事。我只是个帮佣。
But I definitely was wondering if-- what happened to make them stop this vacation? Because she was on a work trip. She was at a conference. And he was going to meet her in that city. I forget what city it was. So my gut tells me this that it was an affair. But that was just me, completely making that up. Part of me wanted to reach out to her. But I was like, that's really inappropriate. I don't know her.
但我确实在好奇如果……发生了什么让他们停止这次假期？因为她正在出差。她在开会。他本来要去那个城市见她。我忘了是什么城市了。所以我的直觉告诉我这是外遇。但这只是我完全编造的。我内心深处想去联系她。但我心想，那太不合适了。我不认识她。
L, of course, recognizes that when big things happen in your life, the dog sitter is not at the top of the list of people to fill in. This couple barely knew her. In fact, if she was doing her job right, when the couple came back home, there'd be no trace of her at all.
L当然意识到，当生活中发生大事时，宠物看护并不是人们第一想告知的人。这对夫妇几乎不认识她。事实上，如果她工作做得好，当夫妇回来时，根本不会留下任何痕迹。
Months passed. And she didn't hear from them. When Christmas rolled around, she sent the a holiday card, like she does with all her clients. The card was returned to sender.
几个月过去了。她没再听到他们的消息。当圣诞节到来时，她寄了一张节日贺卡，就像她对所有客户做的那样。卡片被退回给了寄件人。
I'm not going to say I was hurt by it because that's too far. But it made me a little sad. And I'd really love them to still be together. I want the whole family to be intact.
我不会说我因此受伤，因为那太夸张了。但这让我有点难过。我真的很希望他们还在一起。我希望整个家庭完整。
I wanted to reach out to the couple to find out if L was right, if they really did get divorced. But L, reasonably, didn't want me to reach out. It felt like too much of an invasion of their privacy. And I realized not knowing the real answer, that's actually truer to how these things go. You wonder about people. You try to imagine their lives. And mostly, you don't get to know.
我本想联系那对夫妇看看L说得对不对，他们是否真的离婚了。但L很合理地不希望我去联系。那感觉太侵犯隐私了。我意识到不知道真正的答案，那其实更符合这类事情的发展规律。你会想念人们。你会试着想象他们的生活。大多数情况下，你没法知道。
For so many of the pet sitters I talked to, the things from the pet owners lives that got to them and stuck with them were things they wanted for themselves. That was true for L. It's also the case for this other pet sitter I talked to, Peri, in a very different way.
对于我采访的那么多宠物看护来说，宠物主人生活中那些触动她们并挥之不去的事物，通常是她们自己所渴望的东西。这对于L是真的。对于我采访的另一位宠物看护佩里来说也是如此，虽然是以一种非常不同的方式。
Here are some things to know about Peri. She's 29. She's an acupuncture student. And a few months ago, she started pet sitting for a grieving family. The dad of the family had just died.
关于佩里有几点要知道。她29岁。她是针灸系学生。几个月前，她开始为一个悲伤的家庭做宠物看护。那个家庭的父亲刚去世。
I literally met and went over things with their family about their pugs and their parrot a few days after their funeral. So I'm filling in for him in the grieving period.
我在他们葬礼后几天才真正见面并与他们的家人过了一遍关于他们的哈巴狗和鹦鹉的事。所以我是在悲伤期填补他留下的空缺。
Peri's lost three close family members over the past few years. So in a way, she felt like the exact right person to pet sit for this family. She knew how to be there for them while they were in the thick of it.
佩里过去几年失去了三位亲近的家人。所以某种程度上，她觉得正是为这个家庭看护宠物的合适人选。她知道如何在他们深陷痛苦时陪伴他们。
The family had been a family of four, a mom and dad in their 50s and two grown kids in their 20's, one at college, the other still living at home. The mom and dad had always walked the two pugs together. After he died, the mom had tried taking the dogs out herself, but told Peri she felt a stabbing pain whenever she did. So Peri started walking the pugs five days a week, which meant she was always in and out of their house.
这家人原本是一家四口，50多岁的妈妈和爸爸，还有两个20多岁的成年孩子，一个在读大学，另一个还住家里。妈妈和爸爸以前总是会一起遛那两只哈巴狗。他去世后，妈妈试着自己带狗出去，但告诉佩里，每次她这么做都会感到一阵刺痛。于是佩里开始每周五天遛狗，这意味着她总是在他们的房子里进进出出。
I haven't met the dad, but I'm seeing a negative of him in his own life, his house and his yard that-- apparently he designed the whole thing-- and animals and the kids and all the pictures and stuff. And--
我没见过那个爸爸，但我看到了他生活的一个负面影像，他的房子和院子——显然他设计了这一切——还有动物、孩子、所有照片之类的。而且——
Like you can almost see the shape of him because the absence is so clear?
就像因为缺失如此明显，你几乎可以看到他的轮廓？
Exactly. He's there even if he's not there.
没错。他即使不在场也依然在那里。
Peri started noticing that she would think about the dad while she worked. When she'd take the pugs for a walk, she'd think, what was it like for him to walk the pugs? How did he react when they barked at all the other dogs? When she'd greet neighbors, who clearly recognized the pugs, she'd think, they must know why I'm here, walking them. It must be strange to see the wrong person holding the leash.
佩里开始注意到，她在工作时会想到那个爸爸。带哈巴狗遛弯时，她会想，他遛狗时是什么样的？当它们对着其他狗吠时他有什么反应？当她问候那些显然认出这些哈巴狗的邻居时，她会想，他们一定知道我为什么在这儿，替他遛狗。看到错误的人牵着狗绳一定很奇怪。
One afternoon, Peri couldn't make it over to walk the dogs. She'd misplaced her phone. So she hopped on Facebook to find the mom's profile, to send her a message there, to let her know.
一个下午，佩里没法过来遛狗。她找不到手机了。所以她上了脸书找妈妈的资料，给她留个信息，告诉她一声。
On Facebook was, obviously, pictures of her and the family. And there's a picture of him in their front yard, with the dogs, leashed up, like they're about to go on a walk together. And it's something that you know but you don't-- if you imagine something, it's not the same as seeing it.
脸书上显然有她和家人的照片。有一张他在前院，带着狗，系着绳子，就像他们正要一起去遛弯。那是你知道但你不……如果你想象某件事，它跟亲眼看见是不同的。
And so it makes it more real. And it feels like oh, that must have been an important part of his life. He was smiling and-- ooh, that's the dogs that I walk every day. And that's the person who used to walk them.
这让它变得更真实。感觉就像噢，那一定是他生命中重要的一部分。他在笑，而且……噢，那是我每天遛的狗。而那个人是以前遛它们的人。
It's weird how something you see in someone else's life can totally turn you around. About a month ago, Peri had a moment like this, that she still thinks about.
奇怪的是，你在某人生活中看到的东西有时能完全改变你。大约一个月前，佩里有过这样一刻，她至今还在想。
They were all making crawfish in the kitchen. And I was letting the dogs back in. And I was like-- it was just this perfect little family scene. And then the dad's not there. But you picture how he would have fit into that little scene because you just get this little snippet of their life like that. And--
他们都在厨房做小龙虾。我正放狗进去。我当时……那就像一幕完美的家庭场景。然后爸爸不在了。但你会想象他如何融入那个小场景，因为你只是得到了他们生活中那样的一小片。而且——
How do you picture he might have fit in?
你如何想象他可能会如何融入？
I don't know. I feel emotional thinking about that. (CRYING) I don't-- I don't know.
我不知道。想到那个我感到情绪化。（哭泣）我没……我不知道。
How come it makes you emotional, you think?
你觉得为什么它让你感到情绪化？
Well, my grandpa died last month.
嗯，我爷爷上个月去世了。
For the fourth time in four years, Peri lost someone close to her. She was thrown back into that awful, early phase of grief, when everything feels hazy. The night of the crawfish dinner was right after her grandpa died. And Peri said she felt like she was floating, dissociated, just trying to get through it and get back for her grandpa's funeral the next day.
四年里第四次，佩里失去了亲近的人。她被抛回那种可怕、早期的悲伤阶段，一切都感觉模糊。吃小龙虾晚餐的那晚是在她爷爷去世后。佩里说她感觉自己像是漂浮着，解离，只是试图熬过去，以便第二天能回去参加爷爷的葬礼。
I think the reason that it stands out in my memory is because just seeing them as a family there, and just having fun together after the other times that I'd seen them all together, they were a little bit more somber. And it's just-- when you go through a grief period, and then when you come out of it, you don't realize it when you're coming out of it.
我想它在我的记忆中如此突出的原因是因为看到他们作为一家人待在那里，在其他几次我看到他们聚在一起之后又玩得这么开心，他们稍微显得有些忧郁。而且……当你经历一个悲伤期，然后当你走出来时，你在走出来时并不会意识到这一点。
For Peri, who was just starting to grieve her grandfather, it was comforting to see the family begin to emerge out the other side. It wasn't within reach for her just yet. But it was nice to know it was there.
对于刚刚开始为祖父悲伤的佩里来说，看到这个家庭开始从另一端走出来令人欣慰。虽然对她来说还够不着，但知道它就在那里，感觉真好。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our show.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program today was produced by Aviva DeKornfeld and me. The people who put our show together today include Phia Benin, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Bethel Habte, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德和我共同制作。今天将我们的节目拼凑在一起的人包括费亚·贝宁、达娜·齐维斯、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、贝塞尔·哈布特、卡西·豪利、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、托宾·洛、阿拉·穆斯塔法、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和戴安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Today is the last day for our office coordinator, Charlotte Sleeper. She is off to New Zealand. And I'll miss her. Special thanks today to Ben Calhoun, Mary Fuller, Mitch Harris, John Paul Brammer, Levi Vonk, and Kasia Thomas.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是埃曼纽尔·贝里。今天是我们的办公室协调员夏洛特·斯利珀的最后一天。她要动身去新西兰了。我会想念她的。今天特别感谢本·卡尔霍恩、玛丽·富勒、米奇·哈里斯、约翰·保罗·布拉默、利维·冯克和卡西亚·托马斯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thank you to our show's regular host, Mr. Ira Glass. If I've told him once, I've told him 100 times. Do not help me with my crossword.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过700集的节目存档。本节目由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发到各公共广播电台。感谢我们节目长期的主持人，艾拉·格拉斯先生。如果我告诉过他一次，我就告诉过他100次。不要帮我完成纵横填字游戏。
Today, I was trying to figure out a clue, '90s dram-com with James Van Der Beek. It was driving me crazy. What was it, Dawson's something? Dawson's Landing? And I heard him.
今天，我正在试着破解一个线索，“詹姆斯·范德比克主演的90年代剧-喜剧”。这让我发疯。是什么，道森什么？道森登陆？我听见他了。
Creek. Creek. Creek.
溪（Creek）。溪。溪。
I'm Lilly Sullivan. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是莉莉·沙利文。我们下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。